ise elle estise on pouvait craindre le
pire ce matin national le président
Philippe semblait prisonnier de la
jeunesse pendant que la jeunesse s'en
donnait à cœurjoie en occupant son pè
choix une place de choix qui un Fran
succès je trouve que c'est vraiment très
bien équipé et dans les on fouille
on teste la qualité du fauteuil
parlementaire les micros on se fait
prendre en photo dans les salles plus
illustres éblouissement
général c'est
beau on va pas ça autre part c'est ça
être député junior d'un jour mais pas
seulement vint ensuite la vraie séance
avec le protocole
habituel remise de rapport de travail
par leurs auteurs
délégé
1789 Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme
et du Citoyen nous aussi nous sommes
citoy nous sommes des citoyens parce que
nous avons des idées sur le monde que
nous voulons la parole
est B député de B on aé une dizain de
question au ministre deéducation et
prés dispar deses écoles
r
rairturb nous ne comprenons pasutêcher
cel si on a le sentiment qu'il y a
beaucoup
d'affair c'est parce qu'on a défini des
règles nouvelles qui n'existaiit pas
auparavant du coup la justice président
de répondre avec gravité à toute une
assemblée qui ne perd pas un mot de son
explication une HE dem de débat qui a
passionné et donné des idées à certains
et certaines envie maintenant d'être
député et pourquoi parce
que je servirai à servir les
autres y